bom dia pessoal e eu sempre sonhei em
ser cientista e eu consegui
eu estudo prático e pesquiso a ciência a
inovação porque os problemas que a nossa
sociedade enfrenta ambientais econômicos
e sociais
eles exigem soluções inovadoras e porque
as empresas para se manterem
competitivas para sobreviver e para ter
um desempenho superior
elas precisam de inovação sistemática e
eu aprendi isso muito cedo e a duras
penas
quando eu ainda era criança e o meu pai
faleceu há alguns anos depois da empresa
que ele trabalhava vir a quebrar e eu
queria conversar um pouco com vocês
sobre esse tema e tentar entender por
que que muito do que nós sabemos sobre a
teoria ea prática da inovação precisa
ser reescrito
eu venho estudando esse tema nos últimos
anos e tive a oportunidade de participar
de uma centena de projetos de inovação
corporativa em grandes empresas como
coca-cola boticário volvo está no fim e
fazer e poder ter o aprendizado de que
nós precisamos repensar o entendimento
de quem são os inovadores do que eles
são feitos e como é que nós podemos
formar uma legião de inovadores
eu queria conversar basicamente sobre
três pontos o que está errado nas visões
vigentes atualmente sobre o tema o que é
inovação e como é que ela ocorre dentro
das organizações
em função disso quem são os inovadores
quais são as suas características e como
é que eles são feitos
o ponto central daquilo que nós
aprendemos que precisa ser redefinido
é de que aquela visão do gênio criativo
isolado que resolve os problemas
empresariais e sociais
é uma visão ultrapassada a idéia de que
inovação é desenvolver um novo produto é
uma visão limitada e exclui uma boa
parcela das pessoas que não trabalha com
o desenvolvimento de produto nas
organizações
a idéia de que a melhor forma de
estimular as pessoas a inovar é por meio
de estímulos financeiros desconsidera a
essência da proposta de valor da
inovação e o entendimento de que é
possível reunir em uma mesma pessoa
alguém imaginativo e analítico concreto
e abstrato é na realidade uma utopia
nós aprendemos que pra conseguir
entender quem são os inovadores e do que
eles são feitos nós possamos voltar a
entender um pouco que que a inovação
inovação é transformar novas idéias em
resultado seja ela o doutor consulta o
modelo de atendimento de saúde
alternativo um novo modelo de negócio
como uber uma nova tecnologia como a zap
a diferentes tipos de inovação mas há
dois elementos comuns nos diferentes
tipos de inovação
primeiro o fato de serem projetos que
ele não com alto grau de incerteza e que
quando dão certo
gera um enorme impacto resultados para
quem 91 segundo é que essas diferentes
inovações
elas passam por quatro fases dentro das
organizações
a primeira fase é a fase da idealização
quando de forma espontânea ou induzida
as oportunidades são identificadas e as
idéias são geradas
a segunda fase é disso que nós
denominamos a cadeia de valor da
inovação é o que nós chamamos de
conceituação quando a oportunidade é
aprofundada pesquisada no sentido de
aumentar as chances de êxito de algo que
é incerto e poder avaliar a sua
viabilidade técnica ea sua viabilidade
comercial
no entanto 95% das inovações têm alguma
alteração substancial entre a ideia
original e aquilo que se transforma em
inovação
a terceira fase dessa cadeia de valor da
inovação é a experimentação um processo
estruturado de respostas às hipóteses
que haviam em relação àquela idéia para
que a quarta fase dessa cadeia de valor
e inovação a implementação possa então
transformar aquela idéia originalmente
desenvolvida posteriormente refinada
prototipar da testada e pilotada num
projecto que vai ser executado em larga
escala e que é quando efetivamente o
inovador captura valor dessa
oportunidade
no entanto como fica evidente ao
analisar essa cadeia de valor
a criatividade é um apenas um dos
elementos necessários para transformar
novas idéias e resultados
cada uma dessas quatro fases da cadeia
de valor da inovação requer um conjunto
específico de atividades para ser bem
executada
esse conjunto específico de de
atividades requer um conjunto também
específico de competências para as bem
realizar aquilo que você faz para ser
eficiente na idealização é absolutamente
distinto
daquilo que se faz para ser eficiente na
execução do projeto e compreender as
competências necessárias em cada uma
dessas fases é o primeiro passo para
entender como nos transformar melhores
inovadores
bom o que nós descobrimos ao longo dessa
caminhada que existem quatro perfis de
inovadores e não apenas um único perfil
com um conjunto extenso de atributos e
muitas vezes tendente ao criativo
são quatro superfície primeiro o criador
aquelas pessoas que são muito boas em
identificar oportunidades e que tem
motivação para a mudança para levar as
coisas adiante
é um papel fundamental na cadeia de
valor da inovação
o segundo perfil é o que nós denominamos
de refinadores pessoas que não são tão
bons geradores de ideias mas são muito
bons desenvolvedores dessas
oportunidades que não sabem partir do
zero mas à medida que há uma idéia
embrionária eles conseguem vencer um
grande desafio de inovar dentro de
organizações que é ter a primeira milha
da idéia dentro da organização
o maior desafio das organizações não
está em gerar idéias em mover as idéias
dentro de uma organização que prioriza a
operação do dia a dia em detrimento
daquilo que é novo
o terceiro perfil é o que nós
denominamos do experimento a dor pessoas
que são muito boas na capacidade de
tolerar a incertezas de lidar com
desafios e de fazer adaptações
isso nos projetos ao longo do seu curso
o quarto perfil é o que nós denominamos
de executor aquela pessoa que não é o
criativo mas que tem uma alta capacidade
de transformar aquele projeto piloto
aquele protótipo aquele experimento em
algo em larga escala seja ele uma
inovação social
uma inovação empresarial de produto ou
de modelo de negócio
sete são as competências que formam
esses perfis os criadores são fortes em
motivação para a mudança e identificação
de oportunidades
os refinadores são fortes e sim
comportamento com relação a desafios e
tolerância às incertezas os
experimentadores tem alta tolerância a
incerteza ea capacidade de adaptação
durante os projetos enquanto que os
executores tem alta orientação para
resultados e capacidade de gestão de
projetos
o primeiro um site do entendimento de
quem são os inovadores e como formar
inovadores a entender esta conexão fases
da cadeia de valor dos projetos se
desenvolvem perfis que têm uma hora e
menor eficiência em cada uma dessas
fases e as competências que formam esses
perfis
o criador é muito eficiente na fase de
idealização e muitas vezes pouco
eficiente na execução
eu vivi uma circunstância com o cliente
na forma os desenvolvimentos um projeto
há um longo tempo estávamos num final de
semana aguardando o lançamento de uma
determinada iniciativa com o auditório
como esse cheio e na noite anterior à
pessoa que era o criativo da equipe me
ligou
nós estamos com pressa convidada
sei que rodas da empresa selecionados
para participar desse lançamento e na
noite anterior ele me ligou e me disse
eu tenho uma idéia eu desliguei o
telefone disse muito obrigado falando
daqui a uma semana
isso não é mais um momento desse
contexto
da mesma forma é bem possível que você
já tenha vivenciado nas circunstâncias
de negócio de vocês e na vida pessoal
aquela pessoa que faz o papel do
advogado do diabo
tudo que alguém levanta ele corta e
ainda tem assim é a transparência de
dizer alguém tem que fazer esse papel na
eu fico pensando mas porque sempre tudo
sofá sempre o mesmo papel
e esse é o segundo site este papel no
desenvolvimento de um projeto inovador
ele é bastante útil no momento adequado
na fase de idealização este papel é
contra producente ele não é bom ou ruim
e não é útil no momento oportuno ele é
útil esse entendimento de onde cada
perfil pode ser mais eficiente é um
segundo entendimento que nós entendemos
que é fundamental para formar uma legião
de inovadores
isso nos seja o terceiro tema que é como
é que eu formo pessoas com essas
competências e aqui vem o alento
fundamental
dois terços das competências dos
indivíduos para inovar não são inatas
nós não nascemos inovadores ou não
inovadores e seguiremos assim até o fim
dos tempos
essas competências elas podem ser
desenvolvidas de diferentes formas um
treinamento formal com discussões como
essas que nós estamos fazendo aqui um
benchmark junho
organizações e indivíduos que são
referência naquela determinada
competência mentoring a partir de
pessoas que podem orientar e e provê
conselhos para desenvolver essas
competências e com a melhor de todas as
formas que é vivendo esta realidade
lidando com projetos inovadores e mais
do que isso
estando consciente de qual é o meu
perfil
qual é o momento que o projeto está
vivenciando quais são as competências
úteis neste momento e como é que eu
posso botar a serviço do projeto
aquilo que eu tenho de melhor no momento
mais adequado
isso permitirá que cada um de nós possa
render mais na posição certa e também
que as organizações possam formar os
melhores times para desenvolver as
oportunidades
a inovação é um fenômeno organizacional
dependente da colaboração entre as
pessoas
os criativos não são os únicos
importantes nesse processo
o aumento da taxa de acerto das
inovações que hoje no contexto
empresarial é bastante baixo em torno de
70 85 por cento dos projetos de inovação
corporativa fracassa passa por formar
melhores inovadores e isso passa por nós
temos entendimento de qual é o nosso
perfil
aqueles que quiserem conhecer o seu
digite no google depois indicador de
potencial inovador tem um acesso lento
que dá o teu perfil e as suas
competências indicador de potencial
inovador um tema fundamental
a inovação é importante pra sociedade
para as empresas mas a essência da
proposta de valor da inovação tá em que
ela acessa o que o ser humano tem
necessidade mais sublime conforme a
pirâmide das necessidades que o marasmo
desenvolveu que a necessidade de estima
e de auto realização
não há sensação melhor do que saber que
tu fez o que não tinha sido feito e que
isso trouxe um impacto positivo pra ti e
para os outros
essa é a essência da inovação e isso
traz para as pessoas que têm essa
oportunidade a melhor das sensações
eu queria convidar vocês a seguirem essa
reflexão porque nós seguirmos tomando
decisões sobre um tema tão relevante com
base em conhecimentos ultrapassados
seria como médico seguir dando remédios
obsoletos por falta de informação
e vocês qual é o seu perfil inovador
muito obrigado